Here are some factor pairs for negative 24. I made the first factor negative in
each of the pairs. I know that none of these pairs could sum to negative 5 since
the greater number is in the right hand column. All these sums would be
positive. If I make the second factor negative, I can see that the sum of each
of these factor pairs would end up being negative. So, the factor pair of
negative 8 and 3 sum to negative 5. We can rewrite our negative 5x and negative
8x and positive 3x using these two factors. When our factor pairs are negative
and positive, it's generally easier to list the negative term first. This makes
our factoring by grouping a little bit easier. We can factor our 4x from the
first two terms, and a positive 1 from the second two terms, since the only
factor that these two terms share is 1. I used brackets around this part of the
factoring because I have parentheses inside. For this inside bracket portion, we
have common factors of 3x minus 2, so we can factor that out, leaving us with
our final complete factored form.